this is a production of Cornell
University
well thanks a lot for this nice
introduction and it's really a great
pleasure to be here with in the back
nice poster of Barbara McClintock so the
place to be and there's always a kind of
battle and always also see these numbers
with the number one University in the
world well I think we should not discuss
that at all I think it's nice to see
that a couple of centers in the world
that do good plant science and
agricultural research and for sure
Cornell is one of them and I think also
happening is a nice center where a lot
of different disciplines come together
so as introduced we work on a lot of
different species in my my group a
little bit of working tomato quite a lot
in cauliflower since 2012 also lot in
boobs plant species mainly focusing on
syrup but for the majority of
understanding the underlying molecular
mechanisms but I will talk about today
we still do that in Arabi Dobbs's so for
those who are coming especially for work
in crops have to disappoint them but
there are a few steps towards
cauliflower and also one small step to
tomato so I don't know who if you have
ever been at botany University but in
one thing you have beated us your campus
is bigger nicer much better I would say
but we have also a new campus that's
what you see see over here with two
major education buildings and it's all
quite new it's I think about 10 years
ago now to be moved from all buildings
within bartending and campus just
outside and it's nice in compact and
with about 500 thousand students
nowadays and a you see it from the other
side and what is a good thing of it
surviving itself is just here on the on
the side so it's directly adjacent to
athlean it's not only university
buildings but this one is for example
the dairy company the research
department of Friesland Campina so
there's a lot of integration also if
spin-off company so this whole building
is full of spin-off companies but also
big place in the food and agricultural
industry and you see here this grass
field in between at this moment
Unilever the big food company decided to
combine all their research in Bosnian so
at this moment they are making a huge
building here actually filling up the
whole space between these two buildings
and it will
about 500 researchers very soon start
there so the whole unit Eva research
will albeit at the campus which gives a
lot of opportunities for for
corporations directly with the industry
oh this is the plant science feeling can
nicely recognize it from the green Sun
screens cause only on sunny days
otherwise it's just glass that you see
and in the back you see that the
greenhouses and also here's some
research fields where we do the
experiments with the crop the field
crops so what I will talk today about is
farm adaptation and just to start off in
the end it will all be our adopts us but
I think I don't have to tell that here
but often they have to convince people
why plants are so interesting and one
thing that is it's really a remarkable
of clowns is there a tremendous capacity
to adapt to all different kind of
environments as seen here on this
picture and it's also needed for plants
because plants are sessile organisms and
well when it's called we walk inside and
protect us in that way from from cold
temperatures but plants have to find a
way to survive and they're all different
kind of conditions that they don't have
any influence on and they just have to
take it as it comes well they are so
successive in conquering the world you
see also see that's here you have of
course optimal conditions high humidity
a lot of nutrients high temperatures but
you see there's also in a lot of
competition so what makes plants so
successful is they adapt to their
specific environments and it can either
be very harsh environments but the good
thing is there's less competition or
very rich environments but then they
find ways to compete with other plant
species well if you want to adapt your
whole growth cycle way of living
structure to the environment if you need
ways to measure the environment and
there are of course a lot of different
signals nutrient levels day length light
quality but also temperature is a very
important signal and in our lab we focus
completely on how plants and in this
case urban topsis is able to adapt it's
all growth to the temperature well in
this respects you have to realize that
there are two major differences in
temperature you have two more extremes
it can either be stressful temperatures
but also in
Orton temperatures and for that a very
nice example is fertilization that means
winter cold
so our adopters accessions coming from
northern countries they need in order to
flower a long period of winter coat so
this to prevent that they will not set
seed in the in the autumn but they need
a long period of cold and only after a
long period of cold in forming a lot of
rows at leaves they are able to flower
so this is called the colonization
response so quite extreme another
example of that is breakers of dormancy
what you having a lot of trees or these
bud breaking the buds are you see it
nicely now outside we see all this fruit
tree starting to flower these buds need
cold in order to open up and to to
flower besides that there is the ambient
temperature response and it's much less
studies in general that's just a daily
fluctuations in temperature and a lot of
people think well one day it's warm the
other days will be colder it doesn't
matter that that much the plants are
measuring that very precisely and if I
change their development based on the
temperature they measure and that here
you see one one of those phenotypes that
is in growth the fall so if you go to a
slightly higher temperature you see that
in Irbid of cystic petals start to
stretch and also the leaves are standing
more straight up and this is to do in
this case you can imagine that you can
have more aeration so the pound as far
more cooling capacity higher
temperatures due to this change in its
morphology well we do a little bit on
those growth aspects but the main
biological process we are interested in
is flowering time and that is also
heavily responding to temperature the
forum is Asian response but also to
ambient temperature and that's what you
see here when you grow Colombia at
different ambient temperatures or here
is blue here red but this means colder
this means warmer but even a two degrees
difference in efforts temperature can
already speed up the flowering can
double the speed for flowering so it has
a tremendous effect on on flowering time
in a particular range and another
productive trade that is very much
influenced by by temperature is seed
dormancy so seeds after they are
produced they depending on the
temperature they can also moisture
leaven a lot of other signals they
decide to to germinate or not but also
their level of dormancy that they have
at the moment they are formed it's it's
well known that that depends not only on
the temperature that they the
germination does not only depend on the
temperature they are experiencing when
they already seed but also the
temperature that is experienced by the
plant before or during the seed set that
is determining the level of dormancy and
it was already long known that during
flowering the temperature then so at the
moment that seeds are developed and
embryo is developing temperature matters
but quite groundbreaking work of the
Steve Banfield lab at your minister
Institute at UK they showed that every
dog has fans that are exposed to cold
temperatures during the vegetative stage
and then move to warm temperatures as
soon as it starts bolting so during seed
said it's warm temperatures the seeds
that you harvest from those plants are
more dormant that means that it's not
only the temperature that the seeds
experience themselves but also the
temperature that the plant is
experiencing that is taken into account
for seed dormancy and it also means that
there must be memory so there must be a
kind of memory of this temperature our
plants don't have brains and it's of
course interesting how does such memory
work I will come back to that later on
so what you see here is so I just showed
you that urban office colombia gets
early flowering but in this response
there's a lot of variation so hasty
flowering time of all kind of herb
adopters accessions
now you compare 27 to 22 degrees you see
you nice to get colombia flowers earlier
and you see that the majority of
accessions flower earlier some far more
extreme than colombia but as you can see
there are also exceptions that when you
increase temperature they decide to
flower later so you see this all rains
of responses depending on ambient
temperature and then you also see back
in crops so cauliflower also a brassy kc
very close to our adopts us in that
respect from the same family but it
responds different in colombia so if you
go to a higher temperature then the
induction of flowering which is the
induction of
herd formation which is one big
inflorescence gets delayed so slightly
increase in the ambient temperature
delays skirt formation and it's not only
delaying curd formation it's also
affecting them the outgrow of the
inflorescence
so off the curd you get a more open curd
due to more stretching of near
fluorescent stems so temperature is a
clear-cut effect on also on our crops
and small fluctuations in ambient
temperature can affect a lot when we can
harvest our crop and what will be the
quality of the harvestable product well
then of course a question that we have
to answer if you want to study
temperature how do plants measure
temperature do they have a kind of
thermo meter somewhere in their
structures and for mammalians that is
quite well known that and that's maybe
also not so strange that there are
membrane proteins and membranes I think
we all learned during our physical
classes that their fluidity is depending
on temperature so you could imagine that
there are membrane proteins that can act
as thermo meters but if people looks -
based on homology to this kind of
proteins that are them in the membrane
and since the temperature in mammals
they were not able to find anything that
looks alike in plants it doesn't mean
it's there is not a membrane protein but
at least this classical temperature
sensors they are not there well then is
of course the question what is then
measuring temperature and then once more
I think it's good to realize if you look
- do you really meet a temperature
sensor or is it maybe inheritant - all
the molecules and the latter is the case
because we all learned that folding of
proteins looping of RNAs all that is
temperature sensitive so maybe there is
not a general temperature sensor in
plants but just the molecules that play
a role in growth and flowering
themselves by their stability folding
protein interactions all that kind of
characteristics can sense temperature
and we more and more start to believe
that that is the way how plants sense
temperature nice examples are of that
are a recent paper where they showed
that phytochromes
phytochrome B which is known to change
this is way of structure on the
influence of red or far red light
its structure its stochiometry can also
change on the temperature so phytochrome
bees that they made your light signal a
receptor but it can also act as
temperature sensor by changing is and a
hole folding upon a difference in
ambient temperature another process that
is heavily temperature dependent is gene
splicing so in eukaryotic genomes are in
the majority of genes there are introns
and depending on how these introns are
excised you can get different final
transcripts but your transcripts and
coding for different proteins and it's
gene splicing appears also to be highly
temperature sensitive and that is what
we focused on over the last five years
and we will show the most of so when we
started this project it was already
known that splicing is heavily affected
by temperature and then we thought well
can we get more genome wide inside in
which genes undergo differentially
alternative splicing and you will see
this term days you will see it back a
lot of my slides which means
differentially alternative splicing and
this it's transcripts are now all
sensitive for the splicing room
temperature so what we did is we have
been growing our bit of suspense at 16
degrees and the showed a condition so
it's not flowering in ducting conditions
and then we grout it for five weeks they
are still perfectly vegetative we also
tested that but by looking to leafy and
a pedlar one so floor immersed emeritus
and then what we did is after five weeks
we switched half of the pants to twenty
five degrees so still ambient so it's
not stress temperature a real subscriber
at 25 and then after exactly one day
three days and five days we have steak
we took samples of the meristem enriched
so the meristem plus the young leaves
and from that we did RNA seek and then
de novo assembly to see all the new
splicing variants that maybe are going
to appear and we decided to take exactly
24 hours later three and five days to
have no influence of the clock because
it's very well known that clock teens
get also differentiate by so if you
didn't sampling after for six hours and
swarm it's very difficult to figure out
what is ongoing so that's the reason why
we took the first sample after exactly
24 hours
well to summarize that if you look to
which means our differential alternative
splice they are here you cannot read
anything there but it's about 1,000
genes I will zoom in late from under the
type of genes so it's definitely
something that it's not just mispricing
because of a higher temperature because
then you would expect that the majority
of genes are differentially alternative
splice it's a specific said and I will
show you they're also specific classes
of genes and it said that it's there are
more sensitive for this temperature
slicing what you also see is that when
you compare 16 to the 25 samples the
biggest difference is between 16 and 25
day one they see a lot of differences
and then it directly more or less
stabilizes so it's a very fast response
but if you keep the plants at the warm
temperature they also keep this altered
splicing ratio only when you place them
back to low temperature this swap again
so the conclusions here were many genes
on the goal differential alternative
splicing but there seems to be some
specificity it's not just simply
mispricing and it's a fast response most
uses occur in the first 24 hours well
what are then the genes that are
differentially alternatively spliced
well if we look to over-represented gene
ontology terms which was not surprising
we find back flowering and we knew the
flowering is heavily temperature
dependent and so we see that many of the
flowering time Dean's go differentially
alternative splicing so this was as
expected but what we didn't expect at
that moment was that all the top classes
are RNA splicing mRNA splicing RNA
metabolism RNA processing so genes
involved in splicing itself so it makes
it complicated because then you start to
think how is that possible alternative
splicing is changing but the genes that
are needed for alternative splicing they
are the most heavily differentially
spiced when you change temperature oh
probably of all of you um how splicing
works from your textbook knowledge for
me that was the same and we started this
work and I know the splicing as a
complex thing with many proteins
involved but I didn't realize how
complex it is nowadays there are almost
400 proteins known that are needed in
this old splicing machinery so it's not
a very simple cutting of introns out
it's a very complex machinery
of and set of genes that are involved in
this and when we started our work it was
already known that genes encoding for so
called as our proteins are same in
sharing rich proteins that are in the
core slicing machinery that they are
alternatively spliced but what we
realized is that actually all the
different type of genes that are
involved in splicing many of them gets
differentially spiced for you change
temperature so temperature has a very
strong effect on the whole splicing
machinery at all different kind of
levels well based on that became to
today's this model and what you see is
that when you change a mean temperature
you get a very fast response especially
in a splicing related genes that's an
initial response as a consequent of that
you get an altered splicing machinery I
was out of complex of the splicing
machinery proteins and there then as a
second boost and act on developmental
genes which then gets differentially
spliced reading finally to adaptation of
the phenotype to temperature for example
late flowering or stretching of these
materials oh this is a model but current
working model that we have a question
then of course is what are then these
developmental genes that are
specifically differentially surprised by
this splicing machinery because in the
end there are the genes that are
important to change the traits of the
plants so when we look at that this is
just a small example list you see here
different genes so flowering locust M
also known as Mets affecting flowering
my free math to PR R so the clock
proteins a you see the slicing event re
means in from retention exon skipping
after 95 or 23 mutually exclusive
excellent so you see also that
temperature affects all these different
types of splicing it's not that only in
stronger tense you know whatever is
affected all the different types are
affected and any AC the splicing ratios
particular isoforms 16 degrees 25
degrees and so you see that in some
cases the effects are quite big but you
also see that sometimes the effects coil
mouth it's significant but it's not that
in once you change from eyes inform one
two eyes form two it's often a small
switch in in their ratio
another important thing is what you see
is that it's quite stable so that's
indicated here so this means that at one
day three days and five days we saw a
significant difference in comparison to
16 and you see that the majority of
affects is very stable and you change
temperature it's changing and it stays
like that well this is a selection but
we see many of this muff like proteins
and ns the question what added for a
kind of proteins that are then
alternatively spliced the genes encoding
them and these mufe like genes they all
belong to the Mets domain transcription
factor family and I've already mentioned
in the introduction our lab is mainly
focusing on transcription factors I was
very happy to see this candidate genes
and that's also why we focused on these
genes it does not mean that other teens
are not differentially spliced but we
focused on transcription factors and
these muffins they are quite interesting
because the major gene in the
formulation responds in arabic OPS's is
fo c so this is the g m-- responding to
the winter cold and all these others
here that are close relatives of fo c
due to duplications of the FOC locus my
form of tumor free three of them undergo
differentially alternative splicing so
it seems that both cold and warm
temperature every axon this FOC clade
members and in that way change flowering
time so more in depth it was already at
that moment genetic data for from the
lab of del fuego at in germany that
especially FLM is a major player because
if you AC again the thermal sensitivity
so the change in flowering time when you
change from 22 to 27 degrees so you see
that's almost twofold genes in that the
fastest flower that if flowers faster
and in fo M mutant
this effect is almost completely gone so
you see a ratio of one meaning that it
flowers at the same moment as low
ambient temperature and I am in
temperature so FM is a major player but
also is sisters brothers how you want to
call it these other duplicates they have
a clear-cut effect that's what you see
here you see a muff two mutant so
normally again wild-type 21 degrees
early flowering 16 degrees late
flowering and you see that at Mayflower
in their mouth two mutant is much less
it flowers but exactly at the same
moment that you see already quite
effect and that's also what you see back
here you see the muff - the two major
isoforms very and one invariant - and
you see at 16 degrees you see mainly the
small one and when you go to 27 degrees
you see mainly the top one but it's not
black and white again another one ma
free that's more complicated this is
data from an RNA seek from our own lab
and what you can see there is that there
are even six different isoforms
I mean you change from 23 to 16 you see
again that this bottom one here is
disappearing some other ones are getting
more intense
so you see difference in the ratio of
these isoforms or what you can see also
here for my free we don't have Newton
data to show that this is really
important for the flowering time but one
thing that is also good to realize this
was based on RNA seek and de novo
assembly from all this isoforms that we
identified so this was RNA seek there we
identified them then by QP sha we could
confirm we've cut all these bands out
and sequence it and it were exactly this
isoforms which I predicted by the by
invitation but only two of them are
available in tier so that also shows
that splicing a lot of that information
if you want to study is yeah looking at
the ter database although it's a very
rich resource there is a lot of
information still missing and there are
definitely a lot of novel either forms
that are missed in this in this
databases well then the question is how
can one two different transcripts from
the same gene with a small difference in
it sometimes only a very small extension
somewhere in the middle of the protein
have such a different function in
flowering time so that was the next
question we asked and for that we
initially focused on on EV elem so FLM
is is one of these represses and it's
the major one that's when you ever
knockout is almost completely
temperature insensitive and if you look
to air for them you find in colombia
mainly two isoforms beta in Delta and LM
has nine excellence which is quite
complicated gene but you will never find
a transcript in which all nine exons are
present so it has a so-called mutually
exclusive exome so you find either exon
2 in the transcript and we call it beta
or you find X from 3 n we call it Delta
but at that moment we did together with
the lab of Marcus sweet overexpression
of these different isoforms and if you
overexpress the isoform it is the most
pronounced at cold temperature you get a
late flowering bound whereas when you
overexpress the delta variant which is
the most pronounced at high temperatures
you get an early flowering so confirming
that the switch in isoform intrinsic
into the protein by changing a small
piece in the middle of the protein you
change its functioning from a repressor
or flowering into an activator of
flowering that's what is summarized here
so at low temperatures you have mainly
better so maybe the repressor you get a
late flowering plants whereas at high
temperature mainly the activator you get
an early flowering plant or we are
molecular biologists and then we were
not satisfied by this we also said what
is the underlying mechanism how can two
proteins that are very similar do a
complete different function so for that
we did a bunch of experiments mainly in
vitro experiments DNA binding protein
protein interaction studies and it's
already all published quite some time
ago so I will only show the final
summary of that before we could figure
out that at low ambient temperature you
have mainly Evelyn better and Evelyn
better is a transcription factor that
needs to dimerize with SGP another
Matchbox transcription factor and it can
bind as a complex that we've shown by
tip seek experiments to for example the
FT promoter the sub promoter so floral
activators and they repress its
expression when you go into higher
ambient temperature you get less of
better you get more of Delta Delta can
also form complexes with SUV but this
complexes cannot bind DNA anymore and in
that way you get competition between
these kind of complexes which are in
principle non-functional so you don't
repress the floral activator anymore and
these repressive complexes and in that
way two proteins that are very similar
by binding to the same interaction
partner SGP if if they are function well
i mention already
is mainly based on in vitro work and on
ship seek experiments after this
publication a lot of discussion came is
this model model correct and there was
work from syrettes Lamas Romanian he's
now in Australia as this paper in nature
plans and what they say actually this
model is not correct because FL M Delta
the transcript that we show with the
mutually exclusive third action
according to is lab that is not existing
and what is existing is a transcript
with an interim retention so you get
less better but you get more of a
transcript with interim retention and
these transcripts are targeted for nmd
nonce is mediated RNA DK so what is
happening at a low ambient temperature
you have a lot of beta that gives a
functional protein doing its job but at
a higher ambient temperature beta is
going down but you have a lot of Delta
but it's never making a protein it just
gets destroyed so still the splicing is
important but the Delta variant is not
leading to a functional protein its
leading to a transcript that just gets
degraded well can be but at that moment
that was the model and there was another
study from a group in in Germany they
did experiments looking to a natural
variation and according to them Delta
was also not important but they did
experiments up to 23 degrees and we know
the Delta starts to kick in at higher
temperatures so gets story is completely
correct what they published but they
didn't look at exactly the right
temperatures but based on those papers
now the whole community is against it
and well I guess it up because I think I
can spend the rest of my time of my life
on figuring out what is it now and we
have to interpret the proteomics to see
can we detect and the Delta Rho T but I
don't know if there are proteomics
experts here but you do it based on
peptide detection and the difference
between better and delta is only one
large peptide which is very difficult to
catch in a proteomics
essay so we try to do that with targeted
proteomics but we never managed to get
that well running but still I thought I
want to at least be sure that the
transcript is there that we proposed
that should be there so for that reason
we did recently but bio run by ISO SEC
in which you isolate transcripts and
just secret them from beginning to end
and then you know exactly which
transcripts are
present you don't use buying partitions
to predict based on all the small
alumina fragments what are the isoforms
and if we did that for FLM well you can
probably see already there are far more
than better in Delta and I will not go
into that we have detected I think 27
different isoforms but it's very
complicated I will not go into that but
a good thing is we see a lot of better
but they also expected and that's with
excellent to win it you see here an
example here here there are many I I
just marked a few arrows there any
question is is Delta there and yes Delta
is there so what Australian people say
that Delta is not formed it's not
correct because we see this new tree
exclusive excellent we found here one
here one we found transcripts of Delta
so Delta is definitely there so that
does not say that they are wrong because
they say that it's an interim retention
and yes that variant you see it here
we also found so I think the end of the
story is that it's not that black and
white it's just there are all these
different variants and plants use
probably both mechanisms the Delta which
is destroying part of the transcript did
the one with the interim retention and
the true doubt that it may be leads to a
protein and that's combination of those
effects you stand there a nice elegant
response to ambient temperature yes so
to conclude this part
flm splicing it's very important in the
FLM Delta either form well it is
definitely there and probably it is
especially at higher ambient
temperatures kicking in and having a
role but what I think is important to
realize is that independent or four is
the final fate of the transcripts the
process of alternative splicing is very
important for the temperature response
well the trigger is also to look into
crops because in the end it's nice when
you noted for herb adopts us but if we
cannot live from so you would like to
know can we because that's that's
definitely something that for example
cauliflower growers want they do not
like that if they get a warm period
during the vegetative stage that their
harvest is to free weeks later and that
the product that they harvest is also of
less quality so they would like to
generate temperature in sensitive
cauliflower lotharians so for that
reason we also looked while is
maybe conserved this pathway and can be
based on what we know from every Dobbs's
picked by jeans and make mutants in poly
flour and come to temperature
insensitive cauliflower so what we did
is so cauliflower I showed them when you
have a lobe immune temperature you get
nice curve formation a tyramine
temperature it's delayed and you get a
less faulty Curt so we did a very
similar experiment where we grew
cauliflower for five weeks at normal
ambient temperature so 22 to day 79 and
then we switch them to high ambient
temperature for one week and after one
day exactly 24 hours again we took a
sample for our NAC
after one week we placed them back and
grew them at a normal temperature and
the final consequence of that that one
week of heat around week five is enough
to get a strong delay in incurred
initiation so then we did again our in
asia differential gene expression
analysis and alternative splicing
analysis and hoping that it's conserved
but if we did that we saw that the
conservation at splicing level was only
six percent so it was very disappointing
because we hope to find a big
conservation but actually the conclusion
was it's not conserved at all well then
we of course we're disappointed but they
looked a little bit better into it what
is then that that overlap what are kind
of genes for which at least there is
conservation and then we saw that ten
percent of those six and overlap so one
out of ten is a splicing machinery
gained so it seems that the effect of
temperature on the splicing machinery
that that is quite conserved but then
the genes that are then selected the
flowering time genes or the growth genes
that give you refine or response to
developmental genes yeah that seems to
be if our eh so based on this became at
this tomorrow that's which maybe
conservation at a mechanistic level so
alternative splicing plays a role but
it's not that the same genes are
targeted and currently but yet
cauliflower is slow we have now our
crisper mutants we had last week my
technician came very happy that we have
five first seats of almost I expressed
four mutant in one of these splicing
factors and also in some other flowering
time Dean so hopefully we can show later
on by functional conformation that
really when you start
walking out these jeans that you can
also get on temperature insensitive
cauliflower but it's at this moment
wishful thinking well that was
disappointing and you can think there is
maybe no conservation at all of the
finally targeted jeans but it's also not
the case and we were quite surprised
there because originally I'm coming from
a from a metal main transcription factor
labs who have been studying mr. main
transcription factors like like FLM and
FOC in many different species so we
could look as there may be than another
species where there is alternative
splicing of an FOC like gene and to our
surprise in tomato we found em vp8 which
is very close to muff two in sequence
and for that we found two splicing
variants one it's like these two exons
and the foolish priced variant and then
when we checked what is the response of
the splicing on temperature we saw very
nicely that MVP 8 splicing is
temperature sensitive
so again FLM like FOC like transcription
factor for rhesus pricing is temperature
dependent and well at this moment we
have only correlation but also in tomato
flowering time is affected by
temperature if you think I'm a complete
different temperature regime so we go up
to 30 degrees custom 8o grows normally
at warmer conditions but then still it
responds to temperature with an
alternative splicing of MVP 8 well if
this is causal or just consequence we
don't know so at that moment we still
have to generate the CRISPR mutants to
show that really MVP aid is involved in
this flowering time response upon the
change temperature in tomato yes so the
conclusion there seems to be at least
conservation at the mechanistic level
alternative splicing is an important
mechanism and in some species like
tomato we even found that a similar
flowering time genes gets differentially
alternative splicing to change
temperature well I mentioned in the
beginning when we were doing this
genome-wide analysis that we found
something like 900 genes differentially
spiced
so it not quite a lot but specificity
and then if you start thinking about it
how does the splicing machinery knows
this transcript I have to splice
differently but this transcript not is
there something in the in the messenger
RNA or where is that signal originating
how can the splicing machinery go to the
right load side and directly after that
a pre messenger RNA is made give
differential splicing when you have a
different temperature well for that we
once more made use of what is known in a
mammalian field we do that quite a lot
especially if you look to underlying
mechanisms and oh this is the textbook
picture how I learn splicing and maybe
many of you so that you have a gene with
50 introns in it yes transcription and
if the pre messenger RNA splicing
machinery kicks in cuts out the introns
and you get your mature messenger RNA
which is then moved into the cytoplasm
and translated into a protein well it's
not that this is wrong but it's not that
simplistic as it is shown here and
especially in a mammalian field they
have done a lot of work that shows that
splicing occurs co-transcriptional II so
it's not that first pre messenger RNA is
formed that is shown here and if that
disguise machinery kicks in but the
splicing machinery kicks in as soon as
the polymerase is releasing the
messenger RNA splicing machinery are
sitting already on top of it oh then you
can say well there's a small difference
I don't care it's just a little bit
earlier but what does this mean that
means that splicing occurs very close to
the chromatin and not somewhere else in
the nucleus so and if you think on that
particular genes needs to be checked the
day needs to be alternatively spliced
maybe that is then in the chromatin and
that would be a way to take particular
genes by having a different chromatin
marks and target those for differential
splicing when the temperature is
changing well again for that there was
in a mammalian field already evidence
data showed that there are particular
histone marks for example histone three
lies in 36 trimethylation that directly
are recognized by so-called MRG proteins
which form a direct interaction with
splicing machinery genes so due to this
depending on if this mark is there in
the histones
you can get that the transcripts the
different splicing machinery
proteins are attracted to this
particular transcript
so we were inspired by that and said
let's look to the deposition of this
particular histone mark in Arabi Dobbs's
and statistical mark and also involved
in this ambient temperature dependent
alternative splicing so for that we
first looked genome-wide and we checked
actually in all the expressed genes
where is this mark present and then we
see the tamarcus especially present at
the beginning of the gene so Claude so
quite close to the transcriptional start
site and then it's when you go towards
the end of the gene it drops so this is
the overall pattern and that could was
the same as what other people had
already shown about this mark that's in
this it is different from mammalians
because in mammalian says mainly at the
end of the gene body but in plants it's
mainly at the beginning of the gene body
but then if we look to all the tier 10
genes we see nicely this when we look to
the express genes we see that there is
more D position of this mark and that
was also at a moment when we started our
work people said this mark marks genes
for active transcription so genes that
have this mark are higher expressed well
that's definitely true that's what you
see here if you look to all the genes
and to the express genes you see more
the position of this mark but then if he
took the genes which undergo
temperature-dependent alternative
splicing and we look to the presence of
this mark you see again an increase so
this nicely shows that the mark is
mainly present at the beginning of the
gene body and especially jeans with a
bit with temperature-dependent days are
enriched in this particular mark which
could mean that this mark is involved in
taking genes and telling this genes
needs to be differentially spiced oh
this is a it's a nice way of showing in
a correlation but it's just a
correlation and if you really want to
prove that it's causal then a nice way
is to go to the genetics but first I
would like to show you how we think that
how does mark looks and how we think
that it can affect slicing so here you
see one example and that's the PR our
freedom which has an interim retention
which is when you go from 16 to 25 you
clearly see that it is decreasing in its
intensity and we found it significant
one day warm three days and five days
warm and if you looked into it here you
see that a particular interim retention
if you look then to the deposition of
this histone 3
at 16 degrees and 25 degrees you see
exactly a disposition so this gray marks
the difference exactly at this position
of the interim you see a difference so
in this case it fits very well but if
you are critical than you think maybe
but what about splicing events in the
end of a gene because there you see
hardly any D position of this mark but
if you think on the model that the
messenger RNA is of course flexible and
even at the end of the gene because it's
all flexible it's not not a rigid
structure so the the position of the
mark does not need to be exactly at the
position of the splicing because where
the D position of the markers in genome
they're the proteins will bind that's
attractive splicing machinery and maybe
they affect splicing then over there in
the transcript so we see a very nice
correlation but it's not always exactly
the position of where the splicing
occurs well then the genetics comes in
and luckily for us the D position of
this mark was already very well studied
and if you are even if you're not so
much in all the system modifications
what you have to think of if you want to
make such a nice tone modification you
need a writer and there are the SDG
proteins 8 and 26 well if you want to
get rid of it again you need an eraser
and well-known eraser is dim only 30
that is specifically removing this
particular mark and then you have
readers and there are these MRG proteins
that recognize grommet in that contains
a lot of this histone mark and they can
then directly interact with the splicing
machinery and if the effects at least in
mammalians so based on this information
we went for mutants of these particular
genes and checks other than still
temperature responsive in their
flowering time response so here once
more what we did is we grew our bid
officers at 16 degrees and then we
switched them so we did not do the
experiment continuously 16 continuously
25 then you see that big difference in
in flowering time but we grew them first
for 3-4 weeks at 16 degrees and then we
move them to 25 degrees but still you
see a significant effect the ones that
will move 225 degrees get earlier
flowering and if you see them
and SDG mutant so mutant in the writer
of the system mark you see that this
effect it's almost completely gone and
the plant that you'll see here from the
ratio it gets very close to one so
independent of temperature when the
histone mark cannot be deposited not be
written in the in the drama team the
plants becomes temperature insensitive
what about eraser when we have a mutant
for the eraser we see an increase but if
we over FS the eraser again which is
mimicking you know House of the writers
we see again a decrease so also in that
respect it fits the data that the
presence of this mark is very important
for temperature dependent splicing and
finally the energies so there are more
mo g proteins so we could get end on the
double mutant emoji one mo g2 and also
that although it's not black and white
but we see in the response in that plant
become less responsive to to temperature
so to conclude this part normally when
the histone mark is present then on the
cold temperature and warm temperature
you get a difference in flowering time
due to the B position of this mark but
if you have plants in which this mark
cannot be deposited because the writer
is not there or the real designer there
you get a plants independent of the
temperature flower at the same moment
all they are doing now in the follow-up
project is trying to figure out what is
now the exact cause of this effect on
splicing and there are two options again
coming from the mammalian field one is
that it is this so-called adapter model
that this mark is recognized by these
MIG proteins and then the splicing
machinery is docking on that another one
is a so-called kinetic model because
it's very well known that depending on
which kind of marks you have on the
histones the polymerase can go either
faster or slower and studies have been
done with slow down polymerases or
polymerase for mutations and if the
polymerase goes faster or less fast
there is more time for the splicing
machinery to do correct splicing and
it's known that speed of polymerase can
also affect splicing so we have now two
models one is the kinetic model maybe
it's due to the presence of the mark the
speed of polymerase is changing or it's
the adapter model is to binding by the
energy proteins
one other thing that I promise you in
the beginning to come back to its memory
and plants can memorize temperature and
if you think how do plants memorize they
don't have brains so there must be
another mechanism to to memorize
something and histone marks it's very
well known OSHA for the thermalization
the code is memorized by depositing
particular histone marks in a grommet in
and here you see the same what he does
it deposited the system three lies in 36
in the chromatin so maybe the memory of
temperature
Xfire this particular histone marks that
is also something we are currently
following up in the lab to see if the
memory for ambient temperature acts in
the same way a lot of details at the
molecular level but i want to add one
more final detail in the regulation
again a complete different mechanism and
that has to do with what we've seen now
splicing differential expression a lot
of different aspects but if you look to
this F or C clade members especially FLC
it's known that it's regulated by
so-called long non-coding RNAs and there
are many of them cool air called they
are called rep fo CASL and maybe you
know about them so these are rnas either
transcribed antisense from the FOC locus
or incense or sometimes from the
promoter or intronic and they affect the
final expression of FLC very recently it
was also shown that for ma for there is
an alternative anti sense transcript
along non-coding transcript regulating
its expression so we came with the
question are also the other family
members maybe once it's are in the
ambient temperature pathway also
regulated by long non-coding RNAs well
the good thing was we had already that
RNA seek done one three and five days
and we did it de novo analysis so I had
looked at that moment a very good
my interpretation in the lab and he
could look to changes in long non-coding
RNAs upon this temperature change and
that was it's the same as 50 splicing
many of them are not in ter the same
holes for the long non-coding RNAs they
are hardly and here and we could find
actually many so-called natural antigens
transcripts wrong antigenic
transcript and intronic long non-coding
RNA see total around 2000 from its half
of them were new the other half already
annotated in some papers so then of
course the question come that's nice but
you are not going to study 2,000
different long coding RNA so you want to
to come up with ways to to select a few
that are may be enforced in your process
and for the ambient temperature change
so to change from 16 to 20 we had around
50 long coatings that really change
their expression when you change the
temperature and among number 11 natural
anti sense to intergenic once the link
and to intronic to intronic ones and 37
into genic ones
well then 50 is still too much to follow
up by functional studies so we came up
with all kind of arbitrary ways to
reduce this set and what we did is we
for example loops are they may be in
close vicinity to flowering time genes
because the long run code is can act in
all different kind of ways but many of
them are located close to the locus
where the axon and we also said well if
they are important they are probably
conserved so we also checked the instil
in coding RNA that we have found to be
temperature dependent also present in
other species and by doing that we could
bring down the set to a very few and one
of them I will show you the reason so
it's called a T long encoding 4 to 8 and
this was very nicely differential
between 16 and 25 degrees and as you can
see here it's conservation so you see
that at the complete sequence level it's
0 so in for example camelina and Erebus
Alpina
some other brass occasionally but even
if you go to Solon age here you can find
small pieces of the long non-coding RNA
that are still conserved so that gave us
the feeling that it's not a kind of
artificial strange transcript there is
some conservation of this transcript so
there
two mutants and you see that eighty link
mutant when you compare again 25 to 16
you see that the effects the difference
in flowering time is reduced and
especially at low temperatures you see
where it's the highest expressed so if
you mutate it it starts flowering
earlier so again another level of
regulation where low non-coding RNA is
probably affecting affecting the immune
temperature response I didn't say
anything on the FM's the only one that
we found related to these moths genes so
we were hoping to find the similar ones
like cool air and cold air for FC but
these are definitely not there we have
not found any long non-coding for 40
moths
the only thing what we found if you
found any promoter of moth to there we
found a long encoding but that they
didn't follow up yet so I have a new PhD
who is studying more all these long
coatings one thing that I have to say
it's known that the long columns are not
all polyadenylated and our library was
made based on poly a tail so it can be
that we miss Parton or non-coding so it
is still possible that there are long
encodes for for the MAF genes but we
missed maybe so based on that we see a
flowering phenotype we renamed this long
encoding and F linked its antigenic one
so flowering long and staining
non-coding RNA well then back to where
actually my work in the field started as
was also in the introduction these mess
works transcription factors they don't
act on their own reacting complexes and
if all these members therefore CFL M
muffs and any question is with are the
interaction partners and our data and
also if they're also regulation idea at
those genes in for the muffs they can
interact among each other they don't
have a lot of interaction partner some
of these Metz's interactive many of them
like the several other genes and
proteins but the mosrite specificity
with SVP it's name is already saying
it's short vegetative phase so also a
repressor of flowering so fitting and we
were interested in which complexes are
exactly form
formed with SVP and and what is the role
of s should be in this whole ambient
temperature pathway
or one thing that we know about s
repeats in this when you knock it out
you get an early flowering plant and
then you overexpress it you get a very
late flowering plant so it's definitely
a repressor of flowering like the FC
played proteins and it's not only in the
ambient temperature of our FA but it's
also a new phenomena zation parfait it's
in your giver Lim parfait so it's it's
clearly an integrator of flowering
signals it's in in many of the different
environmental factors that affect
flowering somewhere in the pathway SVP
laser roll so that makes that we said
well SP can interact with FOC flm and so
on but is that all and can dad explain
its difference in function in the
ambient pave the feminization pathway
and the Gabriel in path they are there
may be other proteins in these complexes
that give is its specificity so to study
that we generated the line where we
express the SVP from the genomic extra
pecan structure from its own promoter
tech to GFP in SP mutant background so
we complement with the SUV mutant and
every date lc/ms so quantitative
proteomics and we looked can we identify
proteins that are probably in complex
with with SVP but I will not go into all
the technical details but after a lot of
repetitions also in different
backgrounds we figured out that SVP can
interact as expected with FLM FOC so
this one for the fertilization pathway
this 140 ambient temperature pathway but
we also filed quite a nice set of new
proteins which are not known to interact
with SVP some of them have known
function like histone deacetylases
forgetter one PDS 5 but also some hunk
means unknown so we also found some
completely unknown ones which had no
annotation at all at very interacting
with SVP so what we did then is then we
said well how to discriminate in that
and in which proteins to focus on so we
first all that mutants for actually for
a lot of the putative interaction
partners that we found and we check do
they have a flowering time phenotype and
well then the one with the most wrong
flowering time phenotype was unknown to
and for that reason we decided to focus
on that on their protein more and here
you see the phenotype and it's quite
interesting because if you can
to an SVP mutants super mutant gets
early flowering but the unknown to
mutant gets late flowering so it's in
complex 54 a repressor but the phenotype
is opposite so it means that it's
somehow a mediator of the functioning
but it's counteracting the function of
SVP well it's name that we gave it is a
quite complicated both I don't know if
there are Indian people here but the guy
in our lab who figured this out Astrid
Jim day he's from India and he from some
quick if it's this beautiful name I
liked the translation the one who allows
it to flower or blossom it's late
flowering but pouch for me it was a
little bit difficult to pronounce but we
stick to his name because he found a
gene and it's a nice way of naming the
gene if you looked into pulse it's a
huge encodes for a huge protein of 784 -
it's in which you can find hardly any
domains there is a nuclear localization
signal limit and there is this glutamic
acid rich area which could maybe act as
a transcriptional activator but based on
its complete structure most likely it's
a chromatin remodeler so let me take it
well if it is interacting with SVP
where's that interaction occurring and
what is it doing
so we expressed SVP in protoplast here
and although a CP is a transcription
factor if you express it on its own in
protoplast you see it mainly cytoplasmic
and then when we co express it with pals
we see that quite nicely the signal
moves from the cytoplasm into the
nucleus so somehow puff is one of the
factors that can bring SVP into the
nucleus also FOC and evelyn can do that
when you get this heterodimer it also
efficiently goes into the nucleus but
this if there's a confirmation that
probably it's through interaction
because we have tried to confirm this
interaction by yeast two-hybrid studies
and we never managed can either be
because the powerf is a huge protein
that is not expressed well in yeast or
that interaction that we found by the
mass spec is an indirect interaction
that's rather bridging proteins in
between and currently we are following
this up in the lab all to end up the
whole story what is then the function of
both with sgp to be honest we don't know
yet so we are currently growing the post
mutant and all other kind of mutants and
the different
fertilization conditions and the
different ambient temperature conditions
see we found both interacting with SVP
but in this specific pathway is it
needed or is it needed in all these
pathways but there's one interesting
case there SVP it's know it's name is
also according to that it's a flowering
time regulator but there was a study a
big transcriptomic study done years ago
where they based on transcriptomics came
with this network analysis and look for
hubs so genes that are really central in
his net worth for in this case draught
tolerance and ABA signaling and it's a
plant cell paper there they call it a co
22 but hey so 22 is SVP so SVP was found
as a hub in the drought response and we
are currently also following that up
because the guy that works in that on
the pulse protein at this moment in my
lab is a Chinese and all the good thing
of having Chinese people in the lab they
can also check Chinese literature
because there is a paper about both 1813
it's mentioned in this paper and maybe
you can read it I have no idea what it's
all written there but he figured out
that people have already been working on
house and they could show that the post
mutant is having an effect on throat
resistance and on ABA sensitivity which
would fit perfectly with the interaction
of pouch and SVP and being a key player
also in the drought response and that is
something we are currently following
following up so to summarize this and
conclude that plants have as you've seen
a tremendous capacity to adapt their
growth and development to the
environment while temperature is
definitely a very important signal in
death and big use of it for timing of
reproductive decisions in order to
guarantee a reproductive success
remembers of the network's transcription
factor family they are key regulators
50m unit temperature dependent flowering
time and control so not only the FOC
clade members but also SVP and I hope I
convinced you that alternative gene
splicing is very important and connects
as a direct thermal sensor to make
plants respond in a proper way to
temperature changes and if that I like
to enter but first I would like to
mention a few people from the lab so
this is from the owner group which
epidural was a postdoc she's now in the
lab of george Coupland
at much fun
hello and see that the majority of the
work on the histone marks and the link
between histone marks and splicing all
the initial splicing work was done by
Leonie Farah is D in my lab she's now in
the lab of Francois Percy in France
sharad City to work on on SVP you know
why is following that up and I'm still
member partly for my time in help
1finity and well he was my PC supervisor
and he still he's really an expert in
all this medicine word so he supervisor
was involved in that and for the
cauliflower work we collaborate with you
on Bishop anima all the bioinformatics
that I show because they just realized
that all this de novo analysis evening a
bit officer could also in cauliflower is
really challenging his long run coatings
to the splicing and in that I was really
happy that I had a de what savoring but
unfortunately he also left to George his
lap all my good people go to Jos
Copeland but I'm really happy in still a
once in a while we we collaborate and
finally the the collaborators are Joss
is also very good collaborator Brandon
Davies Marcus Smith well in muscle Pro
veneers of Utrecht University and of
course I have to think our finances
which include also quite some breeding
companies in the Netherlands Bayer
Syngenta and Rex fan and I really
appreciate their support in translating
all this knowledge to crops such as
cauliflower thank you for your attention
and it's a good question there I can be
honest I think we have some were written
in the in the papers just out end of
last year we checked seven in total this
was the only one that if a flowering
time phenotype we had two other ones
that give a growth phenotype this is
also interesting because temperature
effects also grow but has to be honest
those were not characterized very much
in detail and it was the work of Alicia
she left him it was the end of her
postdoc so yeah we have to stop there
but now if a new PhD and see will focus
more into it also we will do more
analysis on that 50
to make a better selection and for that
also focused mainly on those that are
going back into the nucleus those
longboats or stay in a nucleus and
functioning there's a desire to create
varieties that have various predictable
flowering times exactly yeah that's a
very good point and that's also as
you've seen we have also not solved it
yet but actually that's already I think
four or five years ago then bees
breeders came to us because they work
together with a lab in in Germany
there's also some publications where
they use classical QTL mapping and so on
to try to identify what is ongoing and
there are some temperature insensitive
cauliflower varieties and so you think
well it's easy you just cross them and
you do the mapping and you're done well
they're fused there's a lot of them well
in a few generations it stays but then
it disappears and that's why they said
we need more insight in what are now the
underlying mechanisms and then we
thought well you know it's easy we will
do the same in we completely
underestimated how difficult that will
be but together if the companies we
still have a project running actually
when I'm back the day after we have a
meeting with them progress meeting it's
almost over and we are thinking now
what's on the new project where we will
because it's not only the switch of the
flowering that makes them but also
afterwards temperature is a strong
effect on the whole inflorescence
development and we till now only look to
the initial induction but we hope that
they are willing to also look refers
more to what is happening after there
are all kind of loops and definitely we
decided to look only after 24 hours
because of we knew that the developments
we have also the clock it's already
complicated enough you can also
dissipate in rhythm involved but we know
for FLM we have been looking after two
hours four hours in
you see a lot happening very fast
responses and maybe even have 24 hours I
already feed feedback loops kicking in
and so it is it is complicated and we
have to make the selection 24 hours and
then and so on but definitely there are
things happening much faster and it's a
very complex regulatory mechanism good
point yes that's a good point and in
that have to be have to be honest so
when you when you modify the system free
life in 36 primarily all these they have
a flowering time effective for the rest
you would think maybe it would be very
Playa tropic and some of these remarks
are then you get this very small dwarf
plants but when you have mutants in this
mark that's not the case although you
also see a little bit in vegetative
growth in effect but which flowering
time genes are exactly affected flm is
definitely affected but the ratio that
you see in flm splicing alone is not
explaining the effect on flowering time
so it's probably a combination and that
is also what I showed those appear are
free PR 5:7 it's a combination of all
the genes that gets differentially
spliced so it's also not that when you
remove the mark that you have no
splicing at all but it's sometimes is
that the isoform ratio is swapping in
the other direction and it's very
complicated on some genes is increasing
the splicing other genes it's decreasing
the splicing and we are far from
understanding that so there's a lot to
do there are still three the point is
how many of those genes actually so the
question is how how stable this
temperature memory is and so if you
change it back which of the genes remain
their ratio we only have done in that
respect because we were always focusing
on FLM
and there is work from Steve Penfield
and I must say I trust his data but I
know that there are a lot of labs having
difficulties in reproducing it also
because he's using Columbia and Columbia
has hardly any seed dormancy so you have
to do all kind of tricks to see urn
dormancy effects and if you do it's a
slightly variation in your experiments
it's already gone so we had quite a big
big problem in that but we have seen
four FL MBA flukes and for FL m we have
seen in only the few pilot experiments
and then it stopped so it's for the new
PhD we'll follow that up we have seen
that it's memorized but how general that
is we don't know and if these histone
marks are involved yet I also don't know
and I thought of looking to that but I
decided then if I want to do this for
early I can better do it with a new PhD
and what I will do is select first and a
bit of succession that hasn't very nice
temperature dependent flowering time
response in dormancy response and in
that I will nowadays with Chris we can
easily do that remake the SDG mute and
all the mutants therefore let muted and
then see how it is because I don't want
to have a PC struggling again with this
very difficult Columbia which is hardly
dormant and then we also have to see
it's still a theory in very
hypotheticals it's a good point we
believe that it's like that but we don't
have a lot of evidence yet this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at Cornell edu